ではよろしくお願いします
六十七番お願いします
では 今日もダンマパダというテキストの話になります
六十七番目の偈でございます
ナタン・カンマン・カタン・サドゥ
ヤン・カッツー・アヌタッパティ
ヤッサ・アッスム・コッローダン
ヴィパークン・パティセーヴァティ
ナタン・カンマン・カタン・サドゥ
ヤン・カッツー・アヌタッパティ
ヤッサ・アッスム・コッローダン
ヴィパークン・パティセーヴァティ
という偈になります 今日もありがたいことに
とても簡単なわかりやすい意味の教えなんです
一番単純な意味で我々にわかりやすい
もう極端に省略して言うと
後で後悔する羽目になることはやるなかれということなんです
後で後悔する悩み羽目になるものはしてはいけませんと
ナタン・カンマン このような行為はカタン・サドゥしてはいけない
いけないということは先に来ますね
ナ・サドゥ 良くないと
ヤン・カッツー・アヌタッパティ
どのような行為かというと
ヤン・カッツー やってからはアヌタッパティ悩むことになる
それでサラニ・セッス・ウェスマティ
ヤッサ・アッスム・コッローダン
ヴィパークン・パティセーヴァティ
ヴィパークンというのは結果
パティセーヴァティというのは受けること
報いを受ける時ですね
アッスム・コッローダン
涙流しながら泣く羽目になる
後で結果が出たらもう泣く羽目に涙流す羽目になるんだと
そのようなことはしてはならないんだと
ずいぶんシンプルな言葉なんですよ
それで我々は なんだお釈迦様はそんなことだったら誰にも言えるでしょうと
と思えるかもしれませんだけど
問題はもう 後で悪い結果になることはやってはいけないということは誰でも知っていることなんですね
これが大きな問題なんですね
誰でも知っているならば
世の中はうまくいっているはずでしょうしね
人類は悩むことなく 悲しむことなく
後悔することなく 大変喜んで生きているはずなんです
もし我々は自分の人生を振り返ってみると
いいことばかりだったらね
幼稚園の時はとてもうまくいってよくよく行きましたと
小学生の時は まあなんて楽しいことかと
うまく勉強もできましたと
中学生の時もみんなと仲良くして
その素晴らしい先生たちに恵まれてよく勉強できたと
それで高校生の時も同じ
また大学でも同じく 何の問題もなくうまくいったと
それで自分にはすごく適した自分の性格に合う仕事もとても簡単に見つかりましたと
というふうに人生を振り返ってみると
何の問題もない すごく楽しいことばかりだったら
いかに幸福でしょうかね
過去を思い出すといいことばっかしで
それだったらいかに幸福でしょうかね
しかし まあそうでない人々もいるんですね
いろんなことを思い出して
かなり悩んだり 悲しくなったり
怯えたり 後悔したり 暗くなったり
落ち込む羽目になったり
引きこもりになったり
そういう人々も世の中にはいるんです
しかし どんな人であっても
後で悩むことになることっていうのはやってはいけないっていうことぐらいは知ってるんです
そこで問題はどこにあるんですかね
後で悩む羽目になることはやってはいけないとは知っている
知ってるんだけど 人生を振り返ってみると
悩むことっていうのは結構ある
嫌になること 悲しくなること
自己嫌悪になることっていうのは結構ある
それでどういう風に説明すればよろしいでしょうかね
どう思いますかね なぜ知っているにも関わらず
後になったら悩むことになるんですかね
今日初めて参加なさっている方々いますか？うん
そういう方々ならなんとか知っていると思います
どう思いますか？後で悩むことになることはもうなんで人がやるんですかね
はい うん  自分ではそれが一番いいと思って
はいはいはい  してしまうんだと思います
何にも考えずそれがしたいと
頭では多分悪いことかもしれないと思っても
自分ではそれがしたいっていう気持ちでやってしまう
はいはいはいはい それはすごいしっかりした答えです
そちらの方は違いあります？同じです
うん それもまあしっかりした答えで
で 他の人には聞きません
自分では悪いことをやるつもりは毛頭ないんだけど
やってる時はすごく楽しいんですね
このやってるとこの楽しみに惹かれてしまって
やってしまうんですね
そこに結果出てみると
もう大変なことになっているんです
だから なかなかこれっていうのは大変なことなんですよ
我々は悪いことはしたくはないんですよ
したくはないんだからといっても
結局はやってるのは全部悪いことになってしまっちゃう
まぁ嫌なことですよ これは
悪いことはやりたくなければやらなきゃいいでしょうし
やるつもりもないでしょうし
しかし 一旦ちょこっと時間経過してみれば
やらなかった方がよかったと
後悔することになるんですね
だからそれで我々はやっぱり生きることっていうのはそう楽じゃないということを理解した方がいいんですよ
そんな甘くないんだと
甘く単純で 私は悪いことしたくないとかね
恥ずかしくなるものは絶対やりたくないとかね
そんなこと言っていられる場合じゃないんです
よくよく見てやってるのはそういうことばっかりになっちゃうんです
悪いことと恥ずかしいことと非難を受けることとかね
後ろめたさを感じることとかね
結局そういうことばっかしやってるんですよ
だから人生の成就っていうのは
大変ややこしくて難しいんですよ
それを我々は覚えておかないと
そう甘くないんだと思っただけでうまくいくわけじゃないんだと
ものすごくそのポイントを気をつけた方がいいんですね
結局は楽じゃないんです
幸福にものすごく楽しい
やっぱり過去を思い出すともう何一つ失敗したことはなくて
全部うまくいったと言えばもう想像できないほど幸せでしょ
いろんなことをやってきたんですけど
一つも失敗したことはないとかね
うまくいったと と言えるならば
もう想像できないんですね
この幸せ それは単純でわかりやすいんだけど
問題は我々は一応やるときは喜んでやってはいるんですけど
ちょこっと時間経ってみると
あ やらなかった方がよかったんじゃない？なんで私はこんなことをその時やったのかとか
後悔することになります
それは一つのポイントなんですよ
この悪いことには 悪いことというのはいつでも甘い蜜を入れてくるんですよ
砂糖の衣がきっちり硬くつけてますよ
そうでないと人は悪いことはしません
もう完全に悪いと知ってるものはやらないんですよ
例えば我々人間は決して火を触ろうとしない
踏切をくぐって線路に電車が来る時はそこで立ってみようかなとは
よく見えますから と電車とかね
そういうことはしませんね
それは危険であることはちゃんと知ってるんです
砂糖の衣がついてないんです
遊ぶ道具には包丁とか使いません
剣道やる人でもせっかく剣道だからね
本物の刀使いましょうと
それはしませんね なぜですかというと
それがもう危険であることを
後で大変なことになるということは知っているんです
だから この砂糖の衣が付いていないものは
そんなに大げさな問題じゃないんです
だから自然に悪いことを避ける能力はないっていうことはないんですね
能力はあります しかし
私たちはこの砂糖の衣で騙されますね
誰も毒蛇を触ろうとしないでしょうし
犬はいくら好きであっても全く知らない犬を触ろうとしないでしょうし
はい その点では結構人間というのは守られていますね
世の中といえば危険なこといっぱいでしょうね
車はいっぱいあるし 電車はもう 1本ごとに電車は飛んでいくし
そんな事故といえばいくらでも起こり得るでしょうに
しかし ものすごい少ない
夜12時になってくると
酔っ払いが線路に入ったりして
ひどい目にみんななるんですけど
そんな事故ということにはならないんですね
で 各家にガスがついているでしょうし
電気ついているでしょうし
危ないでしょうに そんなのは
でも事故は起こりませんね
なぜならば みんなこれは全然砂糖の衣ついていないものであることは知っているんです
だから正しく丁寧に扱ったりする
他の悪いことも そのように明確に悪いと見えてくるならば大丈夫ですよ
問題はこの砂糖の衣なんですよ
例えば皆様の家に詐欺師が来る
もう高い値段でとんでもないことを売ろうとする
例えば株を売ろうとする
本当はそういう会社もない
資料も もう何といいますか
フォージドキュメント英語で言うんですけど
まぁ何といいますかね
まぁ偽の作ったもので
決してその人は奥さん
実は私は詐欺師なんですけど
今日は株をなんとか買ってくれませんかと話に伺いましたと言いますかね
詐欺師に限って ものすごく紳士らしくしっかりした服着て
もしかするとかなりブランドの服を着て
ネクタイぐらいででももうブランドのものをつけたりして
持ってくるブリーフケース見ると
かなり上等なブランドのブリーフケースで
そこで作っている身分証明出すでしょうね
あれってすごいなんかプロが撮った写真でできていた身分証明で
そうやってあらゆる面で里の衣が厚くできているんです
それでやられちゃうんですね
それで後で欲張らなかったら
私はもう五百万騙されることはなかったとか
後で悩んだりする だから決して詐欺師は私は詐欺師なんですけどとね
正直に言うはずはないんです
これがおかしいわけじゃないんですよ
それが自然なんです それが世の中の流れなんです
我々なんで失敗するのかで
世に対して説教しているんですよ
それでかなりやられます
だからこの原理主義者みたいに
神様は完全たるものだから
もう完全な世界を創っているんだよと
何でもかんでも素晴らしく完全やと思っちゃうと
とんでもないことになるんです
正しい答えはよく見るとそう成り立ちません
世の中は 世の中は完全じゃないんです
世の中も嘘で騙されたと嘘言うのは普通なんです
考えても 政治家でも嘘真実を言ったらどうなるんでしょうかと
もう全部終わりですよ
世界は 嘘で固まっているんです
騙しで 商売している人々は嘘しか言わないでしょうに
だから我々に弱みがあるんですよ
すぐもう何でもかんでも世の中のことを世の中に説教しちゃって正しいと思って
完全だと思って で 自分の守ることを自分の体にセキュリティつけることをやめちゃうんです
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
自分の体に 自分の性格にぎっしりセキュリティシステムをつけておいてくださいと
世間に説教するんじゃないんです
世の中の泥棒をなくすんじゃなくて
自分の家に鍵をかけておく
どちらの方が安全でしょうか？と
世の中から泥棒根絶するよと思っちゃうと
これは成り立たない話
それで言いたいことは
このこの里の衣ということはね
あるいはもう外でも中でも
ぎゅうぎゅうと お釈迦様が言うのは蜂蜜のごとく甘いんだと
悪いことは やればやるほどもうものすごく美味しい
重視で もうすごい喜びますよ
後になったら消化すると
これを食べたのは毒であると後でわかる
もう遅いんですね 体に毒が入ってからは
キノコにしたっても一番美しいでしょう
毒キノコは 食べられるキノコというのはすごくかっこ悪いんです
美しくないんです で 私はあまりもう
もう弁当しか食べてないんだからね
あまりわかりませんだけど
あの私の 知識で言えばもう食べられるキノコの色まで決まってるでしょう
例えば決してピンク色
赤色ついてるキノコは食べられません
しかし すごい美しいんです
もう一つキノコがありまして
傘がありますね 傘の周りに女性のスカートに何かあの糸で編んだり
何て言いますかね ん？レース
あ そうそう レースまでついてるんですよ
あの傘の周りに ものすごく綺麗です
それで上 なんとなく何かハチミツ
蜜のようなものもなんとかついていて
すごく惹かれます しかし
それは毒キノコで 食べられるキノコっていうのはものすごく質素でね
あの まあまあした 幹の方が白いし
上の方がね 茶色で全然もう格好良くないんですよ
全部そういう形なんです
食べられるものは まあまあ
ちょこっと色がついてる
ヌルヌルしている何かキノコありますね
あれでも自然で見ると気持ち悪いんです
美しい色じゃないんですよ
なんとなく あの黄色っぽくなんですけど
あまり美しい色じゃないんです
だからキノコさえもそういうもんだからね
このこれが生きてる我々にとっては大変です
幸福に生きていたいと思っちゃうと
真っ先にすごい壁が立ち立ち上がっているんです
これが現実であって 世の中の本当の姿なんです
この壁を破る方法っていうのは
ブッダ以外誰も説明してないんです
どういうわけかわかりません
見れば簡単 簡単にわかることですけど
見れば簡単にわかることで言ってないんです
一人一人が自分をぎっしりと守らなくてはいけないんだということ
お釈迦様だけですよ 良心でも自分の
子供でもね あてになりませんよと
期待するなよと 言ってるの
安心するなよと 結構後で悩む羽目になりますよと
だから我が子さえもそういうことだからね
安心しちゃうとどういうことになるかわからないという
我が子であっても その人は世の中に騙されるとかね
ないんで 世間知らずというのも
もう人間生きてないということはどれほどおかしいかというと
このもう何詐欺というんですか
オレオレ詐欺 ものすごく流行ってるでしょう
自分の子供の声がわからない
自分の孫の声がわからない
この女たちはね 私にとっては未だにこれ理解しがたいんですよ
どうやって声で騙せるのかと
一番騙しにくいところでしょう
もう生では声を聞いてるんですけど
電話で聞いたことはないんでありえないでしょうに
人の声はまあどういう風に
どんなスピーカーで どんな機械通して再生したってもわかるんです
あまりにもド派手に今はね
エコーをかけたり 音質を改良したり
波長を変えたりしちゃうとね
まあそこまでできるのは研究所ですからね
あるいは音楽ステレオとかね
そういう専門のところで
そちら詐欺事件じゃありませんだからね
そちらは 1時間ステレオの機械使っちゃうと
こちらもう 20万  30万かかってますからね
そういうところではやりません
もうやっちゃうと損の方が多いんだからね
すぐバレるし またそちらの会社
それでもう終わりですからね
人からまあ 500万ぐらいもう銀行に振り込んでもらったんですけど
こちらはそれには 3億円の商売あがっちゃいますからやりません
だからまあこの無知 人間らしからんですよ
動物でも群れでいたっても我が子わかるでしょ
声で 動物はみんな同じ声で鳴いてるでしょうに
鹿の群れにいたっても
鹿の声は全部同じなんです
それで それでも鹿のもうもう子供はもういっぱい産んでいるんですけど
お母さんが鳴いた途端
その子供たちはちゃんと自分のお母さんだと
私はあれはどうやってわかるのかと
もう不思議ですけどね
人間の耳で聞いたらもう全く同じなんですけど
だから 鳥たちにもその能力はあるは
動物たちにもその能力はあるは
魚にはないんです 魚喋れませんからね
で それ言っておかないと
また後で私がそう言ったと言って攻撃する可能性もありますからね
人間にはないということは
いかに我々はどうなっているんでしょうかね
いかに無知ということなんです
これ どん底 極限に無知で
その上幸せになりたいと
話にならないんです よくみんな勘違いしていることは
幸せというのは神様の恵みだと思っているでしょうに
あれは無知だからこそ言っていることであって
幸せっていうのは気づくものなんです
恵みじゃないんです 神様の恵みだったら
あれほどたちの悪い神様が
いないとこということになるんです
幸せっていうのは自分で気づくもので
といっても もう子供の声わからないんだからね
もう期待はもうもう夢ででもできそうもないんです
大変ですよ だからこのお釈迦様以外
あんまりね いろいろ私もいろいろ調べたりはするんですけど
まあなかなか行ってないんですよ
もう いろんなこのエピソードやら
もうたくさん文学あるでしょうに
我々にいろんなものを教えてくれる
すごいたくさんあるんですけど
すごく面白い話もいっぱいあるし
しかしまあどこかでなんか正しくないんですね
それで世の中に説教することとかね
正義の味方とかね 世間から犯罪を根絶するぞとかね
テロを根絶するぞとかね
犯罪撲滅運動とかね あるいは犯罪撲滅運動って何やるのかということ
犯罪増える運動なんです
で テロを根絶する 撲滅する運動といって
とことんテロを繁殖させるんですね
だから世の中 世直しをするとかね
正義の味方になって悪
悪と戦うんだぞとかね
そういうのは愚か者の思考であって
現実主義者が言うものじゃないんです
現実主義者は別なことをするんです
それで言いたいのは この悪いことはいつでもいっぱい美味しい水につけて
蜜につけてつけて我々に与えているんです
それで我々は無批判で電話一本で
あの 何て言いますか お金を送金するんだからね
無批判でいいことだと思って
我が身を守る行為だと
我が孫を守る行為だと思ってやっているんです
我が子を守ったことにもなってないし
自分にいいことにもなってないんです
だから最初からもう息子に頼まれるとすぐ
お金払うというね それ自体間違ってるでしょうに
息子が借金したんだから
やっぱり払わなくちゃとかね
その考え自体も間違いなんですよ
そういう間違い考え方あるんだから
ああいう風に詐欺は成立するんです
よく調べると そういう人々は本当は何もやってないんです
よくよく調べると 家族のために
孫のために それほど後で振り返ったらもう楽しくなるように
私はこういうことをしてあげた
こういうことをしてあげた
これあの子はね いろいろ問題
悩んでいると 私はこういうふうに慰めて協力してあげてという自慢になる話一つもないんです
だから電話 1本でやられちゃうんです
この際でも まあ何か親らしいことをしようではないかと
それも外れて 親らしいことをして育てた
育てられた子だったら
たまたま悪いこと失敗したっても
できるだけ親に言わないことにする
親にだけ言うなよと 俺はちょっとトラブっちゃったんですけどとかね
すぐお金ちょうだい それを言いません
成り立たないんですよ
正しい家族関係あるならばね
そういうものはね また常識知らない
今度は詐欺のやり方変えてね
あの 何て言いますか 税金の金戻ってくる還付金でしたよね
ということで ちゃんと財務省と同じ文字で印刷した文章が出て
で で 金戻るんですけど
戻るんだったら戻ってくれればいい
なんで自分でお金送金するんでしょうかね
という場合は 世の中のことも知らないってことになるでしょうに
自分が生きているこの国の法律知ったりさえもわからないという
普通税金払っているんだから
ほとんどみんな だから自分がそれぞれの
こちらだったら渋谷区の税務局でしょうに
私のところに来る手紙は全部きちんと渋谷区であって
住所も電話番号も全部ありまして
それで名前も決まってる人の名前で
なんかラブレター来たような感じですよ
もう知ってますからね
ラブレター来た まあ 3万払わなくちゃいけない
それも自分で資料書くものも何もなくね
そのまま持っていけばそれで全部十分でしょうに
これ毎日やってるのに
なんでこの知識能力ないのかとね
そこまで喋ったのは我々いかに脆くて弱くて無知でやられやすいのかということなんですね
それでやられやすいのは
今説明したことはそんなに問題ない
すごくわかりやすいところ
詐欺師に騙されないようにとかね
その程度はわかりやすい
もっとたちが悪いのは
我々は日々やっていることなんですよ
怒った途端怒鳴ったりする
仕事中何かあったらすぐ何とかやったりする
これで後で大変な悩む羽目になるんですね
それが一番わかりにくいところなんですね
安全対策っていうのはなかなかない
で 人間の悪いところっていうのは
このニコニコと笑って喋ると
すごい親切やと 思ってやられちゃいます
自分の仕事するところで
上の上司がもうすごく怒鳴っただけで
これに腹が立って怒って
ストレス溜まって病気になったりする
そちら詐欺じゃないでしょうに
怒ってるということははっきり明確でしょうに
騙してないでしょうに
それで騙し合いなかったら失敗するってどういうことですかね
もし上司が部下を騙したくて
ひどい目に遭わせたくて
失敗させて仕事を辞めさせたい気分でいるならば
それは詐欺でしょ その場合はまあいい
そんなぐらい気にするなよとか言うんです
それぐらい失敗気にするなよ
誰にもバレっこはないよとかね
なんて親切な人でしょうかと
で 本人が言うんだからね
もっと上にこの人をやりましたと
それでやられるでしょうに
そこで上司がなんてあなたこんなことするのかと怒っちゃうと
この人性格悪いとかね
私をいじめているんだと
この連中と一緒に仕事をしたくないんだと
なんで私は一生この場所でこの人々一緒にいなくちゃいけないんだとか
いろいろ問題作るんですよ
結局はっきり言えば騙してくれと言っていることでしょう
騙してくれ 陥れてくれ
不幸にしてくれと頼んでいるんですよ
結局は はい そういうことで我々は常にやっていることを楽しく思っちゃう
酒飲んでる時はすごく楽しいと
後からは大変なことになる
麻薬使う時でも その時はすごく楽しい
麻薬売ってる人も これは厳密に秘密で
もうすごく秘密守って売ってくれるんです
子供に麻薬売った人は決してその親には言いません
親がその人を家に呼んで
あんたそんなことしたんではないかと
あんたしたってどうでもいい
うちの子は使ってるんではないかと
とんでもない もうこの子はものすごくできた子で
我々とはもう仲良くもしてくれませんよと
ありがたいことですよ
お母さんはとそこまで言って守ってくれる
それで息子がなんていい人ですかと
私をしっかりと親から守ってくれたんだと
それでとことん麻薬使うことになっちゃうんです
それでポイント１っていうのは
まあそういうことなんですね
私たちにはこの判断能力はない
これがいい結果になるか
悪い結果になるかということは
それを覚えておいてください
もう自分を誤魔化さないでください
我々には判断能力はない
もう子供を叱るときはもう言いたいことは全部言っちゃうんです
これでよろしいか悪く
そういうことは後のことを判断する能力ないんです
私には判断能力ないということは事実でしょうし
騙しじゃないでしょうに
しかし あまり面白い考え
ではないんだからもう却下するでしょ
汝は神の子であるというと
ありがた なんてありがたい話ですかと
どこかの宗教でみんな光でできているんだと
くさいな人間 ありがたがって
もうものすごいたくさん入っていてね
もう儲かってますけど
光でできて連中がいてね
で そういうふうに嘘を言うと気分よくそこに飛んでいくし
事実を言うと腹が立って却下して出て行っちゃうんですね
だからどうしようかと
だから詐欺師は嘘を言うんです
甘い話を言うんです 世の中は全部そういうことだから
誰も信頼できません では
宗教だから本当のことを言うでしょうかよ
言いません たくさん信者さんが欲しいでしょうに
それで商売成り立っているでしょうに
言うものは全部嘘になるんです
それでお釈迦様はそういう甘いことじゃなくて
まず理解してほしいことが
私たちにはこれいいことか悪いことかというね
判断できる能力はまずない
じゃあだったらどうしようかと
次のポイント出てくるんですよ
それでお釈迦様がこういうこういう行為は悪いことであると
こういうこういう行為は良いことであるとしっかり教えているんです
それもたくさんないんです
暗記できるようにすっごくシンプルに
語られています 善と悪
こういうこういうものであると
言った途端 いかにそれに逆らおうかというふうに
我々の気持ちが出てくるのです
例えば 善 悪行為は十項目でしょう
これって覚えられるでしょうに
言われた途端 その悪事をやりたくてやりたくて
それそういう風になってしまって
それで不幸になるんですね
あるいは簡単単純でね
欲 怒り 無知っていうのは悪であると
だから欲に基づいて 怒りに基づいて
無知に基づいて何もするなよと
そこで まあ善悪を論理的に決めてやるんだから
それほど問題にはなりませんと思います
しかし それは素直にそれに合わせて人生を守ることできるのは
やっぱり人間にとっては判断能力ないんだということをわかった人なんですね
で お釈迦様 この判断能力ないということは何とか解決してあげているんです
我々に判断能力できるように
自分で自分の操縦できるようにとしてあげるんです
しかし 人類探しているのは救ってくれる人なんですよ
そんな親切な人はいません
皆様が妄想している神様像は世の中で一番悪の層なんですよ
不公平でわがままでいい加減で
差別 極端な差別主義者で
極端に残酷な人物像を妄想して
それに神と言っているのです
その人から救ってもらおうではないかと
救ってくれるでしょうね
だからこの人々は誰か助けてくれると思っちゃうし
そんな人を信頼できるんですかね
助けてくれないということをはっきりお釈迦様は言うんです
誰も 結局は自己責任になるんだと
よく見てみようと 全て自己責任になってしまうんです
まあそういうことで この自分の心を見てくださいと
いつでもね まあそれで欲があると
怒りがあると 無知があると
もうその行為は信頼できません
悪結果になると そこでこのもう一つ問題っていうのは
この我々はこの過去と将来に物事を考えるでしょうに
それっていうのは妄想であって
実際は今ですね 生きているのは
今のことはどうでもいい
今これやりますけど これからやりませんだからと
今日だけですと 今日は今日だけ不倫しますと
でも毎日やるつもりはないんだと
そういう生き方ですね
将来に期待する過去をに引っかかるとか
引っかかるとかね その生き方は完全に無知な生き方なんです
だから どんな人でも悪いと分かってやっている時でも
今日だけですと だから我々は現在に心入れる
入れるとほとんど 95%悪いことしているんです
誰いつでも良いことをすると今日だけですよとは思わないんですね
いつでも頭の中で過去か将来か
これだったらダメです
もうどうしようもない
不幸になることは決まっている
お釈迦様はそうじゃなくて
すぐ今現在に徹底的に集中しなさいと
あなた今行為をしているんだと
これが悪いか良いか 今見なさいと
結果ではなくて 行為自体見ればいいんです
将来的な子供は叱らなくちゃいけない
叱らないと将来悪い子になるかもしれません
どうでもいいんです 将来のことは
今こんな言葉使うべきか
今自分が論理的に語っているかないか
今だけに今の行為自体がね
良いか悪いかと 行為が悪いければ結果も悪くなるのは決まっているし
だから今日だけ 今日だけですよという生き方っていうのは
もう世の中でも悪いことする人はみんなもうやってることだからね
毎日やるつもりはないんですよ
悪人たちみんなそう言ってるんです
だから許してもほしがるんで
人を殺して あの野郎はもうもう頭が悪くて
今その時一回だけでものすごく反省してますよとかね
できればチャラにしてくれという
それはありえません 結果が出ると
誰でもやらなかった方がいいんでしょうと反省はしますよ
なんで日本で反省することは随分道徳にしているんですかね
それ関係ない 反省しようが反省しない人であろうが
悪いことはもっともっとやりたいという人ね
それは明らかなことでね
危険ですけど 例えば子供を殺しちゃって
犯人がやっぱりもう子供は殺すべきじゃない
私はすごく反省していますよと
親がものすごく悩んだでしょうと
後になってみたらものすごくわかるんだよと
自分が間違いましたと
そんなことっていうのはどんなバカに見えるでしょうね
誰でも結果が出てくると
やらなかった方がよかった
やらなかった方がよかったと
それでは人生じゃないんですよ
結果が出てからやらなかった方がよかったという生き方
これ変えなくちゃいけないんです
それは世の中誰でもやってること
それは日本の社会は特に反省するってことをすごいありがたく思ったりして
反省することやるなよ
最初から 今更反省したってもしなくても
やったことやったんだから結果が来るんだよと
のを正しい教えなんです
今更反省とか ですから
我々には将来どんな結果になるかということは
だいたい未確定ではないんだけど
だいたいわからないんですよ
だから あまり将来のことを考えない方がいいんです
今はもうビシビシ借金するんですけど
これで私はちゃんと商売をしますから
もう2年でもうかなり 5000万ぐらいは儲かりますからとかね
そんなことっていうのは
もう無知な人しか考えません
今のことで今借金するべきかないかと
それでやっぱりやばいと
危険やと 借金する人は自分の目的
失敗してもお金なら払えるんだよという自信があるならば
借金とってもいいんですけど
一応商売のために銀行からお金は借りる
商売失敗したら失敗したっても大丈夫ですよ
もう払えますからと いうことを今わかるならば
それほど借金ではお金借りることでは危険にはなりません
しかし 我々そうじゃなくて
将来のことはよく考えて
あの 普通は将来のことをよく考えるという言葉自体
すごくいい言葉と勘違いするでしょうね
あの人はよく将来のことを考えて生活しているんだとかね
本当はどうでしょうかね
将来は 大体将来っていうのはわからないもんですよ
だから将来のことを考えてではなくて
今やってること行為自体が良い行為か悪い行為かと
考えなくちゃいけないんです
例えば食事コントロールする人がね
まあ食べたくて美味しいもの
じゃあ明日やめますからね
明日食事抜きますからというで今日食べると
それで明日にかけているんだからね
それではうまくいかないんです
普段も食欲ある人がこの食事コントロールするだけででもストレスいっぱいたまってるんだから
でもやっぱり今日ちょっと余分に食べて明日半分
これありえないでしょうに
茶碗いっぱい持ってご飯食べてももっと食べたいという人にお医者さんがもう半分にしなさいと
言っても半分食べても足らんでしょうに
その人にとっては でもやっぱり今日はもういっぱい食べて
じゃあ明日ご飯やめればいいでしょという感じで
それで元々できない そんなことは
だからお医者さんの食事コントロールは全部パーになってしまうんですね
それから後でまた悩んだりしたってもね
知ったものじゃないんです
反省してもいただいても
心臓発作を起こしたところで
脳出血を起こしたところで反省してくれるんです
やっぱり前々からもう食事コントロールした方が良かったんですねとか
すごく頭いいですね そういうもうだらしない生き方ですよ
だから我々今やってる行為を
これがいいことかなと
そのやってる時観察しなくちゃいけないんです
お釈迦様は自分の息子であったラーフル尊者に教えたことは
やっぱりやる前にもちょっと考えてください
これ怒りか欲か無知かとということよりも
これはいい行為 役に立つか
役に立たないことかと考えてくださいと
役に立つだろうと思ったら
まあやってもいいんだけど
やってる最中も考えて
この行為は役に立つことでしょうかと
やってる最中も 考えておきなさいよと
やってる最中 やっぱり役に立ちませんねと分かったらすぐやめなさいと
やってからも あれが役に立ったんでしょうか
役に立ってないなと分かったら二度とやるなよと
だから そういう風にやる前に
やってる時とやって終わってからという三段階で観察するぐらい
これが難しいんですよ
行為は はい というわけで
後で後悔する羽目になるものはやってはいけませんということを誰でも知ってますけど
実践するのは大変な難しいことなんです
だから悪いことをして
後で反省したっても何の意味もないんです
だから仏教では後悔は悪であると
他宗教では後悔すること
悔い改めることはもう最高な善として認めているんだから
仏教はもう反キリストだからね
アンティクリストだからね
それ自体が悪であると
初めから悪いことをやるなよと
反省する羽目になるんだったら
もうとんでもない人間だと
人間は悪いことを失敗はしますけど
失敗したら反省するんじゃなくて
後悔するんじゃなくて
そこは何とかして 何て言いますか
解決する方向へ行かなくちゃいけないんです
人にダメージ 損害を与えたならば
何とかそれは修復することに
それはポジティブ思考なんですよ
反省しますとか 私はすごく腹が立つんですよ
反省すると誰か誰かとごめんなさいとか言った途端怒鳴りつけるんです
この間も書いてます それで何かもう偉そうなことを私に言って
じゃあ私はもうじゃあ後で直してくださいと
文章のことなんですけど
で もう周りからもうもうもう手も足も伸ばせないし
もう無駄話ばっかりしながら
もうそれで無駄話する無知な連中に囲まれていて
文章は書けるわけないでしょうに
書いたところでいろいろ間違いあって疲れていたんだから
まあまあ私だったらすぐ直せるんですけど
じゃあ明日頼みますから直してくださいって言ったら
まるっきり直ってないんです
私に説教するつもりだけで
この佐藤さんに頼んで提出してもらってください
佐藤さんはプロだからね
まあ簡単にできるし 佐藤さんにそれ言ってないんですね
私はそれに怒鳴ったんです
なんでそういうことするんですかと
それだけ偉そうに説教しちゃったんですけど
実際の仕事になってことをやらないでしょ？あなた方はと
それはすごい もうものすごい大きい声で本当に間違えました
ごめんなさいと それで問題終わったね
あれほど気持ち悪いことはないんですよ
私は人間失敗するってこと知っているし
ごめんなさいで済むわけじゃないんです
それで一生ごめんなさいで生きていられますからね
迷惑ですよ その時に限って私は人を侮辱するんです
日本の常識とは違うんです
ごめんなさい ああ まあはいはい
分かりました と言って慰めてもらいたいでしょうに
やりません 一生残りの心に傷跡をつけておくんです
でなきゃ迷惑ですよ 人類に対しては
逆にその人が失敗だとわかったら
すぐ飛んできて解決法を持ってきたらね
それだったら私はもうじゃあお願いしますということで終わっちゃうんです
それもできない 解決法
私も考えていろいろもうやりましたけど
だからこの随分もう見栄張ってね
ごめんなさい 一色で生活しようと思っても
私とはそれうまくいかないことを覚えておいてください
私を怒らせたければごめんなさいと
私には意味がないので
初めから一度でもいいことすると思ってもないしね
何やってももうもうガタガタでいい加減だと知っているし
だからごめんなさいで通じません
人が失敗したなんて全然全くへっちゃらなんです
全然怒りません 失敗には
私はチェックするのは
この人は自分を育てているのかどうか
ただそれだけ 失敗するのは当たり前で
しかし 同じ失敗 またまたまただったらもう意味がないんです
失敗しながらめげずに頑張ってるんだったら
もう私はものすごい満点で評価するんです
めげない とにかくもう
今度やってやろうではないかという
失敗しないでという態度になると
私はそれはもういい人間であると
だから向上心なければもう付き合う必要ないでしょ
人間と 向上心ない人々を仲間にすることってすごくきついんですよ
向上心があるグループだったら互い助け合いますからね
向上心あるということは人間完全でないということはもう分かった上でしょうね
だからお互いにいじめたり
バカにしたりはしません
だから調べてみると どうもいろんなところでもいろいろ我々の生き方にはものすごい問題があるんですよ
だからごめんなさいとかね
あれやこれやではなくて
自分の行為で何か失敗になって
いろいろトラブルが起こったならば
自分がどれぐらいそこを回復できるのかと
そこが大事なことであって
で 何でも回復できるわけじゃないし
回復できるのかと見て
できないならば だったらどうしますかと
私はいつでも言うのは
ではどうしましょうかということを頭に入れてくださいと
それはキーポイント キーワードなんですよ
では どうすればいいのかと
それが全然ないんです
前例に出した問題でも
ではどうするのかというと
佐藤さんがパーリ文殊と何とか
それはもう彼がそれに合わせてくださいと頼まれたではないかと思って
そこはちょっと振り仮名入れたりしてやって
それはもう問題はないんです
他全部切って捨てちゃって
それだけ良かったんです
だからその瞬間に私の頭にあったのは
あ これは失敗だ ではどうしようかと
こうするしかない 今の時間ではと
五分しかない だったらこれで答えると
相手はどうでもいいですよ
私には ごめんなさいと言ってくれなくても
だから全然怒っても何ともないんです
問題がある ではどうしましょうかと
これは誰がやった問題でしょうかと
どうでもいいでしょう
それは誰がやったっても
問題があったら困るでしょうね
みんな それはもうどうしようかという
だから皆様方もいつでも頭の中でこのごめんなさいっていうことはきれいさっぱり取り消しちゃって
その代わりにどうしようかと
どうすれば？ということを入れておいてください
そうするとすごい活発になります
明るくなります 問題っていうのはいつでも起こりますからね
問題起こらない日はないんです
トラブル起こらない日はないんです
もともと不完全だから
もうどうしようもないでしょうね
それは 誰も信頼できませんし
旦那さんに電話かけても
会社から帰る途中で 例えば牛肉これぐらい買ってくださいとかね
ついでにジャガイモとこれこれ買ってくださいとかね
行ったところで今日鍋料理にしますよと
旦那さんは牛肉は頭に残っちゃって
それだけ買ってきて 野菜買ってきてないっていうことはあり得るでしょうに
[背景音楽]そこでお互いに怒鳴る
旦那はごめんなさい もうごめんな
それで問題解決する？牛肉だけで鍋料理っていうのはありえないでしょうに
その瞬間にどうしようかということでしょう
どちらがどうしようかという答えに答えを出さなくちゃいけないでしょうに
店がもうもう車でも自転車でも行けるところに店があるならば
旦那が「じゃあ分かった
もう買ってきますから」と
そういうこと 奥さんが怒る
もう口を開ける前に飛んでいけば問題ないでしょうに
で 文句ないでしょうに
あるいはそう行けるところじゃない場合はね
行って帰るともう時間半
二時間かかると そうするともうご飯食べられないんだからね
それだったら肉だけだから
じゃあカレーにでもしましょうと
で その解決方法でしょうに
鍋じゃなくて焼き肉にしましょうとかね
それを奥さんが判断することで
どちらかどうしましょうかという答え
問題に答えなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それが正しい生きる方法なんですよ
ごめんなさいじゃないんです
私はあえてごめんなさいという場合は
それで済む問題なんです
それで済む問題もあります
だからうかつに人にぶつかったとする
別に触ってあげちゃうと気持ち悪いでしょうに
かえって新しい問題が起こるでしょうに
その時はごめんなさいで済むでしょうに
家を火事にしてごめんなさいで済まそうとするのはどういうことですかね
だから 理性的な生き方というのはものすごく必要なものなんですよ
どんな小さなポイントにしても
ものすごく理性的に分析するというね
何でもワンパターンで済むものじゃないんです
そんなもので まあだから我々はやっぱり
すごく気をつけてほしいことは
この方もおっしゃったように
その時はすごく楽しくてたまらなくなっちゃうので
これをよく覚えておくと
悪いことをやるとすごく楽しいんです
でなきゃ悪いこと成り立ちません
悪いことの場合はその時楽しい
後でものすごい長い間苦しい
良いことはその時は自分と戦わなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分と打ち勝たなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから やる時はそれほど楽しくないんです
だって 嘘を言わないことであろうか
人に怒らないことであろうか
怒鳴らないことであろうか
怠けないことであろうか
難しいんですよ 自分と戦わなくちゃいけないんです
私は怠けないで頑張るぞと思っちゃうと楽じゃないんです
だから良いことは やっている時は自分と戦うということがついてきます
良いことっていうのはそういう定義なんです
自分との戦いなんです
良いことは だから明らかにやっている時は厳しい
しかし 結果はそれから永久的に幸福なんです
一年間もう寝ないで すっごく苦労して受験勉強する人は怠けと戦っているでしょうに
遊びたい気持ちと戦っているでしょうに
寝たい気持ちと戦っているでしょうに
たった一年だけでしょ
しかし 見事に合格したらそれが一生残るんです
受験勉強しないで友達と遊んだならばすっごく楽しい
勉強するんだと言って親を騙してて
うまくいったらすっごく気分がいいんです
見事に母親を騙しちゃったと
その時だけ それから死ぬまで不幸でいなくちゃいけないんです
そんなところかなと思います
それ以上説明する必要はないでしょうということで
[背景音楽]